Okay, to illustrate the operation of the LSQ we will
do an example. So here I have a loadster Q,
where this is the oldest instruction and this is the
youngest instruction in the Q. Note that the Q is storing
instructions in the correct program order, so basically in program
order this was the first load, this was the second
instruction and so on. This says whether it's a load
or a store. This tells us what address the load or
store was fetched from. This is the sequence number.
Basically, just, going up. And, this is the address
to which the load or a store resolves to, and this is the value that we will get
for that load of store. And let's say that
this is the content of the data cache. Let's
say that the initial content of the data cache
is 42 here, 1 here, 38 here, and 1, 2,
3, 4 here. This load goes first, axises address
3290, which is this one, and loads the value
of 42. Let's say now that this store here,
computes its result,. It basically gets the value it's going to
store. Let's say that it gets 25. Note that
this store doesn't really put that value yet in
the cash. That will happen when it commits. So
this is only that we have gotten the value from
the instruction that produces the register that we will
use as our source value to storing memory. Let's
say that this next load also gets a value
of -16 this time. Now let's say that this load
executes next, accesses the address 3418, and it tries
to see whether any of the previous stores matches that
address. They don't, so it loads the value from
memory. This is the address in the cache that matches
this, so we're going to get 1, 2, 3, 4. Next, this load tries to load a value,
it has the address of 3290, it's going to search upward for the latest
store that still precedes it that matches the
address. And it finds one. This store is
having the address of 3290. So instead of
going to the cache, we are directly going to
copy just the value of minus 17 here. So
now we actually had a load that never really accesses
the cache, it just gets the value from the
store. The next load accesses address 3300. It searches the
previous stores and doesn't find any that match this
address. So it's going to go to the cache and load
from address 3300. And it gets 1. Next, we
have another store to 3290. Let's say that the value
stored there is now 0. Next we have a load
from 3410, it searches the previous accesses for a store that
matches this address and it finds one over here, so
it just copies the value of 25. So again, we have
a load that never accesses the cache because it founded
what it needed in the Load-Store Queue. Next we have a
load to 3290. It searches the load store queue to
find a store that matches this address and it finds one
over here. So it just copies the value of 0
here. Noted by now, there have been several stores to
3290. We always want to get the value from the
most recent one that still proceeds us. Because if things were
happening in order one at a time, this is exactly
what the value should be in the memory location. Note,
however, that the memory location, as far as the cache
and the memory are concerned, still contains the value of 42
at this time, although there have been several modifications.
Why? Well, because the stores haven't sent the values
to the data cache yet. And finally, we have
another load to, 3300. It searches backward to find any
stores to the same address. Note that this is
a load. We don't do that. So there're no
stores to this same address so we actually load
the value from the cache, and the value is 1.
Now let's say that at some point, the
loads and stores start committing. So we will
have this load commit. A load commits by
simply copying the value to the register file. And
now, the oldest pointer is here. This store
commits by putting the value in the cache.
So, now we take the value of 25 and put it in address 3410, so we overwrite
this 38 with 25, and now the store can
commit. .And our pointer moves here, we commit another
store here, so the value of minus 17 goes
to location 3290, so we override this 42 with
17. Now our store is committed, we move the
pointer here. If you remember, we said that we
need to send the values to the memory or
the data cache at the time the store commits
not at the time it executes. Here's why, if at
this point we decide that we are taking an exception, we
can just flush this from the lowest queue, and the value
in the data cache in memory is exactly the value that
should be there as of this point in the program execution.
So just like we had our architecture register file, and we
were copying values and commit into it for register; so that
at any given time we know exactly what the committed register
value are. Similarly, at any given time, we
have in our data cache in memory exactly
what is there as of the commit point.
This process will now go on. The load commits
and deposits its value in it's register. Another
load can commit and another one. When the store
commits, it overrides this 17 with a 0
and then the loads commit. And the final content
of the cache is this.